[Music]
we have a different question from a
different jennifer this time around
what are some ways we can help others
work through their emotional clutter
now i will say this susan and quite
often what we try to do is fix others
because we're we're terrified of looking
inward yeah and noticing what is wrong
with us and then of course every
judgment you talk quite a bit about
judgment in your book our judgments are
are merely insecurities that we're sort
of projecting toward others it's a
mirror i'm holding up of my own
insecurities
so i want to be careful is
one thing is yeah sometimes someone will
come to you and they need help with
their emotional clutter right
and and you can certainly help them and
i think one way we already talked about
today is by seeing them that seems to be
the the main way to help someone hmm
yeah so so
let me kind of
step back in terms of ourselves
and then and then apply to others so
if we strip back all of the research all
of the work on emotional health
what we find is that there are two
core components of emotional
health when we're dealing with difficult
emotions difficult suggestions there are
two core components the first is going
to difficult emotions this is the
showing up this is the compassion this
is the
curiosity like what is this emotion sign
posting so going to emotions is
essential for emotional health and
emotional well-being
very often people try to bypass that
they try to jump to solution they try to
jump to outcome they they have
short-term
fix-its that they try to do well i feel
you know unhappy in this relationship if
i'm just going to leave the relationship
but actually sometimes it's the
avoidance of the work in the real
conversation that needs to happen and so
it feels like a quick fix solution but
actually it's not it's actually a
perpetuation of the problem
so
uh going to emotions is is critical to
emotional health and well-being
this includes um some very practical
things that i'll talk about a little bit
later um if we have time and the other
part of it is going through emotions and
what i mean by going through going
through is about moving beyond the okay
well this is what this value is
signposting it's signposting that i need
more intimacy and connection okay so
what is that then asking you to do it's
asking you in your life to put down your
cell phone and to actually hug your
partner it's actually asking you to make
choices that are values connected so
this is not about like
oh we in our heads
going through emotions is about
being able to connect with our values in
our daily choices because every single
day we have hundreds of what i call
choice points you know
i i want to be healthier like a choice
point might be do i
eat the chocolate cake or do i eat the
fruit like that is a very practical
choice point but we all have them in
ways that connect with our values
and so going through is about connecting
more consistently with choice points
that our values aligned
so this is what emotional health looks
like for ourselves
when it comes to others we know that the
same is true going to and going through
this
often
means that we need to actually really
suburban at the other person you know to
what you were talking about earlier
going to emotions is actually about
not trying to jump in and fix and go
through and like just you know i've got
a solution to your problem the most
important part of being able to support
other people
is
in the going to there are fascinating
studies showing that
if you've got a child who is like
throwing a tantrum on the floor of cvs
your impetus might be to jump in and
like reason with the child
but there is actually very beautiful
research just showing that the presence
of someone
who loves you and cares about you
and who's able to be with you
just that presence de-escalates the
intensity of your emotional experience
and allows you to move from a stage
where you stuck inside the jaw of the
emotion to being able to step out of the
jaw and kind of read what's in the jar
so that someone is i think the most
important aspect of
supporting other people
through
through emotions
what's really important with this is
that we spoke earlier about brooding
and
there is a phenomenon known as
co-brooding
okay so co-brooding is when you go out
with your best friend and
you have a big fat [ __ ] for like three
hours about your father-in-law
and you're like moaning and moaning and
moaning and moaning and moaning and both
of you are like
isn't each other and you're going on
about it yeah and
what happens is so interesting which is
you leave that interaction
loving your best friend even more she
gets me she understands me he gets me he
understands me
but when you actually go back into the
situation with your father-in-law you
are more likely to act out act poorly in
other words that co-brooding is actually
um
when i'm talking about a sauerbona i'm
not talking about getting stuck in the
person's difficult emotions and
difficult experiences
so how do we help them to move to the go
through you you cannot move them
that's not your job
you can support them as they do it yeah
and one of the ways that we can do that
is just by
um
by kind of
helping them even with simple things
like helping someone to
label their difficult emotions so for
example someone who says i'm stressed
okay i'm stressed i'm stressed i'm
stressed which is a very common when we
are struggling very often we say we're
stressed
but there is a world of difference
between stress and disappointment
stress and
feeling unsupported
stress and that no annoying feeling of
you in the wrong job or the wrong career
and so when someone is like
stuck in a difficult emotion and they're
just saying i'm stressed i'm stressed
i'm stressed as a friend helping them to
kind of unpick sometimes
it feels like it's it's this actually
about support
or it feels like this is about
disappointment
what that is called psychologically is
it's called emotion granularity
and this is emotion granularity is a
psychological superpower like talk about
getting uncluttered talk about whatever
we often use these
big umbrellas to talk about what we're
feeling
but when we become more nuanced and we
say it's this you know they're these
crayons in the box and i keep on drawing
on the blue crayon but actually what i'm
feeling is pink
you know emotion granularity asking
yourself i'm saying it's stress but what
are two other options
is one of the most profound ways that we
start getting a level of insight and
clarity and as a friend we can support
people with insight and clarity that's a
that's an amazing question like when
someone
releases an emote or talks about an
emotion you can ask them like what are
two other words to describe that emotion
that'll help them dig a little bit yeah
yeah that's a great suggestion
i was working with a client who would
often describe he would say he's angry
and he would say like i'm angry my
team's angry i'm angry my team's angry
and i started saying to him like what
are what are two other options
and he started saying actually
i'm not angry i'm actually scared
you know i'm actually scared about this
job and my team's not angry my team's
actually
mistrusting
now you can see if you go into a
conversation where you angry and your
team's angry it's a very different
conversation than i'm scared and my
team's looking to bolt you're just
completely different completely
different yeah and when you come home
from work and you seeing your wife as
angry
versus
the person's needing support or the
person's just tired
very different conversation it literally
shifts and emotion granularity when i
call it a superpower what i mean is
that in longitudinal studies we know
that children who are as young as two
and three years old who are able to more
accurately label their emotions moving
beyond just mad and sad in terms of
being more nuanced
literally over
longitudinal studies 10 20 30 years have
higher levels of mental health and
well-being
greater ability to delay gratification
and you can see why this is if if
someone says to a 16 year old hey i've
got this great idea like let's do drugs
together
on the one hand the child like
wants acceptance and connection and that
social contagion is starting to play in
but a child that's more granular with
their emotions is able to say
this looks exciting but there's
something that feels wrong here
and the child is able to connect in with
that is then able to
move forward with those values
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free